احمد البشير اعلامي مخرج وكوميديان عراقي
ما بنبالغ لو قلنا انه الاشهر عراقيا احمد
عنده برنامج ساخر اسمه البشير شو بداوا في
2014 وكان بيعرض على قناه عراقيه واعتبروا
احمد اداء لمحاربه الفساد هو الطائفيه
والتطرف في العراق لكن البرنامج منع من
العرض والان صار على قناه دي دبليو وشعبيه
احمد والبرنامج ممكن جدا نلمسها في اعداد
المتابعين
والمشاهدين فعلى يوتيوب اكثر من سته مليون
مشترك في قناته قريب السبعه يعني هذا غير
الملايين الثانيين في حسابات احمد على
مختلف المنصات وفي رمضان البشير مكمل او
بالبشير شو تحديدا مكمل ومع المواضيع
السياسيه والاجتماعيه المواضيع الرمضانيه
لها مكان في البرنامج
[موسيقى]
حان وقت الافاقه
اجتني القوه اما بالنسبه الهوس اللي صار
على مسلسل دفعه لندن شوف حبي
انا ورا قلت خليني اشوف هذا المسلسل ايش
فيه باول مشهد تطلع الاميره ديانا تركض
وحدها بالشارع ويلحقوها صحفيين ومن دون كل
الشقق دخلت بشقه مال عرب يصبون اكل واول
ما تدخل تطشر الاكل ويا دخلتها بمشهد قديم
متروس راكورات وقرافيكس وبصراحه انا ما
احب المسلسلات الخياليه تبطلت اتابعهم
لا تكبرون الموضوع وبعدين بوسط هذا الكم
الهائل من الاعمال اللي نازله برمضان من
الطبيعي يعني يدور المؤلف او المخرج على
حدث يثير الجدل بين الناس حتى يصير ترند
حتى تصعد مشاهدات المسلسل فلو عايشين
متفرجين مسلسل المهمه اقل احداثها واقعيه
اكثر اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في فقره وجبه
تفسير هنا راح نستقبل الاتصالاتكم وكوكب
الارض
احمد البشير اهلا فيك معانا يا احمد
منورنا اخيرا في الاستوديو الله يسلمك
سنتين صار تقريبا
من جد بس خلاص يلا اخيرا رمضان جمعنا
والبرنامج في
الغريبه اللي بيقول بتقول فيها انك انت
بتوجه الكلام فيها اللي ميل عيدان وبتقول
لها انه حكيتي او حكيتي عن العراق في
غيابي يعني ايش حقيقه هذه التغريده ايش
اللي صاير والله بصراحه اني اصلا ما اعرف
من الامانه
وما اعرف يعني دخلت على الاكونت لقيت انه
هذا الاشياء منشوره فاستغربت
على اكاونتك انت لقيتها منشوره
هل احد مهكر حسابي وكاتب لهذه
معتزازى بها بشخص الكريم ما اعرفها والله
بعدين دخلت على كاونتر لقيتها حاكي اشياء
بعدين معتذره بعدين حاكي اشياء وراها
انسحبت هاي المسكينه يعني عندهم مشكله
الظاهر عائليه ماثر عليها وبعدين
فما شفت الموضوع يستاهل انه يحكي بصراحه
اوكي طيب طبعا مي العيدان لها حق الرد
يعني
يعني ماشي الحال بس انه يعني انا وانت
يعني مفضلين هنكون كتير بس انه ماشي الحال
طيب بس انتم برضو لها حق الرد يعني انت
تحب رغم كل شيء يعني طيب مسلسل
بعدني اذا حابه تقول اي شيء يعني
يعني
طيب مسلسل دفعه لندن تحديدا طيب انت
اتكلمت عنه وتحدثت عن مشهد الاميره ديانا
وكذا بس تجاهلت مثلا الكلام او خلينا نقول
في الصوره الكبيره اللي صارت الخلاف على
هذا المسلسل انه تحديدا انه في عراقيات
بيشتغلوا عند شقه فيها كويتيات او فتاه
فتاه كويتيات ايش رايك في هذا الموضوع هو
انا حطيت المسلسل بالبرنامج قلت له انا
حطيته بخانه
شغلات السايف مو كلش
اي خيال علمي وهذا يعني شفت المسلسل
بصراحه انا اللي حكيت ببرنامج هو هذا اللي
شفته شفت اول مشهد اله ما حبيت المشهد
وتابعت المسلسل اتمنى من الكل ايضا من
يشوف شغله يعتقد انه هي مو حلوه او يعني
اكبر
هي بالحقيقه يعني ما اعرف هو مؤلفه
والمخرج شنو كان براسه
يعني الله يوفقهم بس انا ما حبيت المسلسل
وخلاص ما تابعته وانتهى الموضوع يعني
العراقيين يعني اكو اشياء اعتقد الواحد
المفروض يركز عليها اكثر من هذا الموضوع
طيب اذا عدنا للبرنامج تخفيف موضوع
السياسه هل نقدر نقول انه خلاص الفتره
الجايه كمان حتخفف من موضوع السياسه بشكل
عام لا لا حترجع عادي
للضرب بعد رمضان لا لا العلاقه الموضوع
يتعلق بالحدث السياسي
اللي تصير خلال اسبوع
فاحيانا يكون اكو موضوع مهم لازم نحكي عنه
واحيانا تكون اكو مثلها احنا بمرحله ركود
سياسي خلينا نسميها ماكو ذاك الاحداث
القويه الحكومه العراقيه تحكم من طرف واحد
طرف سياسي واحد شبه طرف سياسي واحد يعني
متفقين على المتحصين نفسهم هم بده يحكمون
اكو حاليا نوع من
السلام بيناتهم المؤقت طبعا
فماكو احداث سياسيه حقيقيه تصير بالعراق
مقتدى الصدر من سحب هوايه برلمان يعني
هوايه ناس يعتقدون انه وجوده كلش مهم وهو
ما موجود فالقصه كلش معقده والقصه كلش
حاليا بنمر المرحله ملل سياسي يعني اسميه
ما راح يستمر ما اعتقد يستمر اليوم اكو
شيء جديد صار فهو يعتمد على الحدث السياسي
وبرمضان غالبا احنا بكل رمضان اول حلقه
نشتغل مواضيع خفيفه لانه
ما يتحمل اول حلقه حلقتين بعدين وراها اذا
اكو حد السياسي اكيد الموضوع الاستضافات
صار في جدل على موضوع الاستضافات
تستضيف اصحابك بعضهم تستضيفهم تلمعهم بعض
الناس قالوا انه يعني هو يقدم لنا محتوى
سياسي وعامل فيها مناضل ومش عارف ايش
بعدين بيجيب لنا اشياء تافهه طبعا انا ما
لي دخل في التسعية طبعا يعني كيف بترد على
هذا الموضوع او كيف بتختار ضيوفك
طبعا ما تحفظ يعني
حتى انا لانه
تافه ابدا يعني
المهم
اكو ثلاث معاير
البرنامج يعتمد بالاستضافات من ضمنها مثلا
انه احنا نجيب الحدث اللي موجود بهذا
الاسبوع ونجيب شخص يعلق على الحدث او يفسر
لنا الموضوع يفكك لنا هذه الشفره اللي مدى
نفتهمها احيانا
شيء مجنون او فعل مجنون او تصرف مجنون
مثلا او مثلا حدث سياسي او حدث امني او
حدث صارت قصه معينه بالعراق مثلا ارتفاع
سعر الدولار
البنك المركز سانت ليغو هذه الاشياء
احيانا ماكو موضوع مهم يتفسر قبل القناه
من قبل البرنامج هو برنامج سياسي اجتماعي
ساخر فنانين نضيف نستضيف امبلز نستضيف
شعراء نستضيف ممثلين كل الطبقات
ونسمع من عنده مو لقاء هو استضافه يعني هي
نصف ساعه تقريبا 25 دقيقه من الحوار
اللطيف الخفيف مو عميق مو بودكاست هو ولا
طالبين بمشاعر لا يعني بس اكو شغله مهمه
اريد اقولها انه كل اللي يجون لهذا
البرنامج
عجبتني مطبين في مشاعر
بسيطه يعني
كل نجوم هذا البرنامج هم شجعان بصراحه
لهذا البرنامج
من التحفظ من قبل الكثير احنا هوايه دزينا
لهم دعواته ورفضوا انه يجون لاسباب امنيه
او تتعلق بشغلهم بالعراق اوكي لانه الظهور
معك تهمه يعني يعني مو بهاي الطريقه بس
يعني هم يخافون يحسبون حساب وين يحترم هاي
القصه ايضا اشكر كل من طلع ويانا البرنامج
ووافق انه يجي او راح يجي او اجى بالماضي
لانه هاي القصه بالنسبه لي تعني للكثير
والجمهور يعني اللي طلعوا هل تعرضوا مثلا
رجعوا سمعوا كلام او تعرضوا المشاكل او
شيء في احد منهم ذكر لك رئيس جمهوريه
السابق مثلا شاركني بفيديو مرهم صالح ورد
علي فيديو يعني كان بيناتنا ما يتعلق
بالتبرع اللاجئين
وصارت عليها هجمه كلش كلش كبيرهم الرجل
كان دا يحكي على موضوع التبرع وده يروج
التبرع للاجئين
فصارت عليها هجمه كلش كبيره انا ذاك لانه
رد علي فقط من قبل الميليشيات المسلحه
واعلامهم
اكو اكو رئيس جمهوريه تعرض لهذا الباقين
شجعان لانه طبوا بعينهم
يعني كله وقبل كذا يعني
كنت في مكان وصار تفجير وتوفوا اللي معاك
وانت نجد
وعندك خسائر عائليه صراحه يعني الله
يرحمهم جميعا يعني كل اللي فقدتهم وانت
بتتعرض لتهديدات طب هذا كله ما يخليك انت
توقف للحظه وتقول طب انا ليش بسوي هذا كله
يمكن هالمستاهل الموضوع حياتي تتعرض
لتهديد وهي القصه تبلش بالمسؤوليه تجاه
الناس يعني تنتهي قصدي مو تبلش تنتهي
بالمسؤوليه تجاه الناس هي بلشت بالبدايه
عباره عن شغف
ايصال رساله ومحاوله انه انا اوصل صوت
هؤلاء
الناس اللي ما يقدرون يوصلون اصواتهم
بعدين وصلت الى مرحله اليوم احنا امام
مسؤوليه كبيره جدا يعني
البرنامج كبرت شهرتك كبر اسمك كل هذا
الكلام بالعراق نفتقد للمؤسسات الاعلاميه
اللي هي مستقله مو مستقله بس تنقل كل شيء
ما عندها خوف من جهه معينه وبنفس الوقت ما
عندها مصلحه وياجها هم انت ممكن الواحد
يقول عنك انك انت كمان ما انت مستقل عادي
قولون استقلاليه ايضا مو يعني عدم
الاستقلال موصف سيئه بس اقصد الاقصى درجه
من الاستقلاليه او اكثر شيء ممكن واحد
يقوله من ناحيه تكون مو حيادي وانما عنده
راي ما يتعلق
بالموضوع فالمسؤوليه صارت كبيره على
البرنامج صارت كبيره علينا فمضطرين انه
نكمل وبنفس الوقت انا والكادر فاهمين جدا
دورنا ودور المسؤوليه اللي ملقات على
عاتقنا قديش حجم الفريق اللي معاك وهل
كلكم نفس التوجه نفس يعني مثلا احيانا
تختلفوا سياسيا مثلا او دائما
على الاشياء بعدين شفنا هذه الخطه فقررت
انه انام
جمهوريتك جمهوريه الديكتاتور اوكي طيب
لمن الان كنا بنتكلم عنها انه محسوبه
الجهات والكلام ده كله حتى انت بيقولوا
انه يعني احمد برضه مثلا تابع لجهه
الفلانيه مثلا او انك انت الامريكان كلمه
اذناب مفضله عندكم هذه كلمه اذناب
كيف ترد
يعني هي هذه التهمه انه
قصه المستقل لازم يحطوله شغله
ما يستوعبون انه اكو فريق
بالعراق يشتغل باعلام مال علاقه باي اجنده
سياسيه والى علاقه بقصه دعم يدعم للحريات
العامه ودائم للحريات الفرديه ودعم ايضا
للعلمانيه بطريقه اداره الحكم فهذا صعب
انه يستوعب على انه هذا فريق مستقل فيوضع
على اي تهمه في اخر شي قالوا الماني
وبعدين قالوا امريكا قبلها طبعا اعتيادي
قطري وسعودي
تركي وكل شيء بس بعدين صارت تسقيط فردي
وصلنا مرحله المانيا وامريكا انا بدي
اشكرك على هذه المقابله شكرا لك مشاهدي
لكن معنا احمد البشير